Loch Ness is a long, narrow lake southwest
of Inverness in the Scottish Highlands.
It is the second largest loch in Scotland
by surface area and the largest by volume.
It is also the second deepest loch, at an
astounding 755 feet (230 meters) at its deepest
point.
The water is dark and murky due to the high
levels of peat in the surrounding soil.
The breadth, depth, and low visibility of
this particular loch make a prime environment
for someone’s imagination to run wild, particularly
when other lake monsters were plentiful in
Scottish legends.
The first recorded sighting of Nessie was
in 565 A.D. by Saint Columba.
Saint Columba was an Irish missionary praised
for spreading Christianity in Scotland.
On one trip to the highlands, he ran across
a group of people burying a man who had been
bitten by the monster in the River Ness.
The Saint supposedly asked another man present
to swim across the river.
When the man jumped in, the monster rose from
the depths and Saint Columba, invoking God’s
power, banished it.
The story was written nearly a century after
the supposed encounter; but even so, it remains
a popular piece of “evidence” used to
demonstrate Nessie’s existence.
The next recorded sighting happened over 1300
years later in 1933.
George Spicer was out driving with his wife
when they saw a large creature walk in front
of their car near the loch.
The creature supposedly had a huge body, long
neck, and they couldn’t see any limbs before
it lunged toward the Loch Ness.
A few weeks later, a motorcyclist claimed
to have nearly run into a similar creature,
describing it as a type of plesiosaur—a
prehistoric marine creature with four large
fins and a long neck, fitting the Spicers’
description.
Soon, with the building of a road along the
loch’s coast, many more reports of sightings
of the monster flooded in.
The 1933 sightings proved to be the beginning
of a long, fruitless search for the monster.
The first picture taken of the monster was
in November 1933 by Hugh Gray.
He supposedly saw a large creature rise above
the surface of the water and snapped several
photographs before it disappeared, but only
one photo turned out when developed.
The picture shows a creature with a long neck
and a thick body, with four lumps at its side
which might have been flippers.
However, it should be noted that critics claim
that the photo is of a dog swimming with a
stick in its mouth… not remotely frightening.
Later that year, a man named Marmaduke Wetherell,
a well-known big game hunter, was hired by
the Daily Mail to find evidence of the Loch
Ness Monster.
He later found large tracks on the edge of
the lake and made molds, but the Natural History
Museum examined them and said they were likely
from a dried hippo’s foot which had become
popularly used as umbrella stands.
Wetherell was fired for failing to find any
substantial evidence.
On April 21, 1934, the most famous picture
of the monster was published in the Daily
Mail.
The picture was supposedly taken by a doctor
named Robert Kenneth Wilson, but he didn’t
like having his name associated with the photo
so it became known as the “Surgeon’s Photograph.”
The picture shows, from a distance, the long
neck and head of the monster rising from rippling
water.
The picture is convincing to the untrained
eye, though critics, certain the photo was
a hoax, claimed it was everything from an
elephant to a diving bird.
It turns out, the photo was a hoax. (shocker)
In 1994, Christopher Spurling, the stepson
of Marmaduke Wetherell, admitted to being
involved in creating a model of Nessie’s
neck and head and placing it on a toy submarine.
The pair then took the model to Loch Ness
and took photos of it in the water.
Wilson was then given the photos because he
was a trusted man, being a doctor.
Wetherell was said to have come up with the
hoax because he was humiliated by his previous
attempt at finding the monster.
Since then, countless videos, photos, and
eyewitness accounts have emerged claiming
to prove the existence of the Loch Ness Monster.
In 1954, the first contact via sonar was made
on Rival III, a fishing boat.
480 feet below the boat, a large “object”
was seen keeping pace with the boat’s speed.
In 2011, sonar contact was made again by Marcus
Atkinson who saw an object about five feet
long and 75 feet below the surface.
It kept pace with his boat for two minutes
before it disappeared.
The sonar image has been examined and critics
have dismissed it as an algae bloom.
However, believers have said that algae couldn’t
survive at 75 feet as it needs sunlight to
thrive, and as murky as the waters of Loch
Ness are, very little sunlight would reach
so far below the surface.
Many other searches have taken place to find
the monster than those already listed.
In 1934, twenty men sat at various locations
around the loch with binoculars and cameras
in the Sir Edward Mountain Expedition.
They remained there from 9 to 6 every day
for five weeks.
21 pictures were taken and examined, but they
were thought to be of seals, not a monster.
In the 70s and early 2000s, Robert Rines conducted
a number of underwater investigations hoping
to find Nessie.
His studies resulted in several underwater
photographs of possible fins and tails.
However, in 2008 he claimed that, based on
fewer sightings and sonar readings, Nessie
had likely died due to global warming…
The most recent photograph was taken by George
Edwards in November 2011.
Edwards claims that it is the most convincing
photograph yet, which perhaps shouldn’t
be too much of a surprise given advances in
easy to use and readily accessible home photo
editing software.
However, in this case, even other Loch Ness
Monster researchers have questioned the authenticity
of the picture, claiming the hump rising from
the water in the picture is actually a fiberglass
model that was used in the filming of a documentary
by National Geographic, which Edwards had
participated in.
With all of the sightings and hunts for the
monster, Loch Ness has become a popular tourist
destination and interested parties can hop
on a boat and travel around the loch looking
for the famous monster.
Of course, Nessie is discounted by scientists
as a myth, but people need something to do
with their free time and vacation dollars,
and this is perhaps at least more scenic than
traveling to the equator and paying to watch
the different way water spins down toilets
and drains depending on which side of the
equator you’re on.
(Note: this one’s also a myth, but you’ll
be hard pressed to find a tour guide around
the equator who doesn’t demonstrate the
differing rotation of the toilet water based
on moving about a mile on one side of the
equator or the other.
In fact, what hemisphere you are in has almost
nothing to do with the way water spins down
the drain.)